ce sont je te le dis toi qu'à 16 ans est
ce que tu lis qu'il faut pas franchement
je kiffe et l'instru est génial l'accord
est clairement entre autres
c'est me
vous êtes surpris en prêt chez bras
m
tâche le seo
aie aie aie aie aie cameroun en plus ce
sera avec moi je vis dans la grande
jarre yade et camille camille lellouche
qui nous pousse jamais vu ça comme un ou
deux de voir comment ch qui cette
personne et j'adore est tombé moi que
single mais moi le single je remercie
mon je remercie beaucoup
appelés pour le présenter moi j'ai
expliqué tout de suite qu'un j'étais nul
en cuisine et deux que moi j'avais déjà
vu beaucoup de concours de cuisine
ouais mais quand je suis arrivé là bas
et que j'ai vu l'émulation vraiment de
tous ces chefs qui viennent la slam
c'est la 8ème annulation ça commence à
ça qu'on voit à l'animateur prend trois
là tu vois c'est à l'animateur tv tout
boyet di régulation mois et non car
imaginons bien l'annulation cannes
émulation vrai ans quand j'ai vu cette
d'arca voilà
avec ses 14 chefs c14 frérot autour de
la table à l'arrêt dit [ __ ] mokhtar
c'est vrai que c'est peut-être le fait
qu arthur les trop vendu il ya aussi
peut-être guillaume moi je pense qu'ils
impriment de concepts dans l'émission
télé on dit toujours qu'une bonne
émission c'est une mission dont on
résume le concept en une phrase par
exemple la chanson secrète c'est des
artistes qui surprennent des autres
artistes en musique la district 7 ckoi
c'est le professeur z qui a laissé
échapper un virus de son laboratoire qui
a contaminé un village qui s'est
refermée et du coup il ya des zombies
qui sont apparus ils vont devoir piquer
des lingots du professeur en coupant des
fruits
c'est incompréhensible et je pense que
les gens n'ont pas compris ce qu'ils
regardent et surtout là où tu es le plus
heureux et et j'ai été heureux partout
j'ai été là je m'éclate vraiment je
remercie mille fois même si je me
laissais faire ça j'ai vécu des années
fantastiques ici voilà cédé un petit peu
si les discothèques des années 80 3 5 3
en bio en cfa m6 et 8 voilà tu crois tu
m'as terminer ta carrière ou là je pense
que tel que c'est parti comme ça je
pense que ça peut être assez vite mais
on n'est jamais
allez s'enticher le contrat y était mis
sa part que tu as vécu là une période
ouais et fiat a perdu du poids mais
j'aime bien du bas c'est le seul
avantage de lakovic et comme j'ai des
symptômes c'est la perte de goût bah du
coup quand on n'a plus de goût on a plus
des piles de fois toi la première fois
c'est compliqué la première fois j'étais
c'était au tout au début la première
vague donc c'était fin mars début avril
et j'ai été diagnostiquée je vais venir
quelqu'un des souhaits ce médecin
mais c'était le moment les tests et des
pas encore généralisée comme maintenant
et du coup j'ai pas été à l'hôpital mais
le médecin m'a dit avec tous les actes
tous les symptômes que vous avez il ya
plus de grip à un moment dès début avril
vous avez la comique donc dans ma tête
je me suis j'ai vu que j'avais la copine
je sais pas si j'ai eu ou pas parce que
je j'ai la deuxième après mais le coup
le leur au vert c'est que du coup j'ai
pris moins de précautions après dix ans
comme j'ai déjà eu je leur ai plus et du
coup bah je prenais beaucoup une
promotion et quand la deuxième vague
arriver à la tête hors de l'eau gelée
pris en pleine tête quoi alors donc le
mans il m'a dit cette phrase elle a
tourné en boucle pendant quinze jours ça
m'a traumatisée si vous n'arrivez même
pas finir une phrase tellement vous êtes
essoufflé appeler le 15
et c'est tout ce qu'on peut faire pour
vous il m'a dit vous avez passé comme ça
donc ça c'est la nuit moi j'ai essayé de
parler doucement pour pas réveillé ma
mère pour voir si je pouvais finir une
phrase j'ai eu voilà en fait j'ai eu
beaucoup de fièvre une fatigue énorme
tous les symptômes mais je m'estime
privilégié par rapport à ceux qui vont
évidemment qui sont hospitalisés doyon
qui savent plus de quoi la ministre
doivent d'abord pour moi parce qu'on a
vraiment à quel âge et je vis dans 1 40
mètre carré avec ma mère qui à 89 ans et
quand je dis ça au médecin la seule
chose qui m'a dit encore une fois on n'a
pas de masque cegedim et je me lève et
je vais la tuer enfin je vais si je lui
passe le coc vite qu'est ce que je fais
il m'a dit on n'a pas de mauvaise idée
vraiment énormément de mobilisation
autour de ça donc oui chaque jour qui
passe on comprend mieux le virus on
arrive mieux à le traiter et peut-être
qu'on arrivera via le vaccin a vraiment
l'arrêter à le juguler mai mais je peux
pas donner de calendrier
cadjee ça te fait peur tous attaqué la
flottille 24 ans ça te fait peur tout ça
c'est que tu te fies pour tes parents
pour bien sûr j'ai très peur de le
ramener chez moi dans la famille donc
c'est pour ça des fois j'ai eu envie
d'aller rejoindre des amis pour qui
faisait la fête tous les jeux
je suis toujours retenu de peur de
ramener cette toutes ces consignes toi
kenji oui je respecte au maximum parce
que j'ai trop peur si je ramène ça chez
moi ma mère et les fragiles maintenant
ils commencent à avoir surnagé tout je
m'en voudrais toute ma vie même sur moi
je veux pas attraper cette ce virus là
du coup ça te manque la scène parce que
telle ou telle porte parole du
gouvernement estime énormément ça me
mène j'aimerais demander ces camps à peu
près qu'on pourrait aller un concert
voir les lacets donner du bonheur
là on est sur un radio là c'est ouais
non mais c'est du coup on a carrément
perdu nous aussi ça nous manquait ça
nous manque à tous
[Musique]
là
on sait à s'amuser on a beaucoup de
travail on sait assez amusé ça suffit on
est en direct et 19h45 c'est ce que ça
représente 1000 heures 45 aujourd'hui il
ya des gens qui nous regardent y ait des
gens qui inventent légende all de l'info
c'est ça que je reproche donc je peux
comprendre que le public ne soit pas
content parce qu'ils ne savaient pas
vraiment à quel moment voter ils
savaient pourquoi vous regarder ailleurs
quand je te parle pourtant ils l'ont
expliqué déjà c'est moi qui pose des
questions nota la print en abaissant
encore garder à jamais ce qu'on pensait
pas l'émission llc plus pour là c'est
parce que vous allez respecter les six
personnes oui oui oui oui oui vous êtes
14 et on va on va faire un petit bout
quoi donc j'avais appelé de trois pères
montois sélection
on a évité de deux ils vont tellement
faire une grande promenade en famille à
l'air libre
sapir je ne sais pas si on a droit faut
c'est un match à jour de l'an pour noël
mais j'aime bien balade mais si dans les
coins et on se donnera les cadeaux voilà
sur le chemin est mais c'est une bonne
chose si tu cherches des mecs n'hésite
pas m il ya aucun souci déjà je vais
vous dire on avance joyeux noël noël
c'est quoi ces gentils noël c'est la
fête avant tout des enfants
c'est vrai c'est les enfants c'est
laisse à penser le père noël et c'est la
naissance du petit jésus c'est l'essence
du petit jésus
mais j'ai j'embrasse ceux qui nous
regardent et les chéris noël c'est la
fête de l'amour a fait de l'amitié c'est
tout ce que j'aime dans cette émission
parce que il cette émission n'est
qu'amour les qu'amitié quel que soit son
âge quel que soit sont pas audités
question d'âge
fazul dit son salaire soit son bronzage
pour interviewer ce soir et pour me
poser des questions sur cette nouvelle
émission qui arrive juste après
l'émission et on certifie que vous étiez
la meilleure personne là bas salaires ou
le chien tu sais que je t'adore je
t'adore et parce que ma vie est sur ma
vie je l'attends oui je vis matin
mauvais c'est une barque à deux roues
fait je vous dis je suis comme aof
tu sais que je te thibault frérot je te
kiffe et autres nous on peut le dire et
on n'a pas eu une année facile a attend
c'était une année difficile pour tout le
monde
cherry et a vu tout le monde a eu l'idée
des galères voilà ils nous on est c'est
la rentrée on avoue n'a voulu rester là
on dirait qu'on a essayé de ne pas
arrêter l'émission
voilà donc on est on est on est allé on
est assez content voilà c'est qu'il ya
juste un truc je te trouve un peu plus
beaux gosses que moi c'est que notre
papa a été touché par l'aco vide
malheureusement comment tu l'as vécu
trois alors ah bah moi c'était bon dans
le confinement en plus donc c'est vrai
que c'était c'est assez compliqué et
c'est vrai que l'on voit là à jeter
j'étais entre les missions et essayer de
m'occuper de lui à distance que je
pouvais pas aller le voir
il a passé lui il a passé quatre mois à
l'hôpital c'est vrai qu'il s'en est
sorti miraculeusement parce qu'ils la
voient là et aujourd'hui je suis très
heureux je vois là mais chaque jour
c'est vrai que je vis dans l'angoissé de
me dire est ce qui va à crysis qui va le
rattraper
est-ce qu'il va retourner l'obstacle ça
reste un traumatisme mais c'est vrai que
voilà j'ai je me suis dit à un moment ça
va être compliqué et bon cyril mon
frérot tu sais que tout le monde adore
je te le dis tu le répètes grâce à mes
hommes il est prête c'est vrai c'est
avec son très fort cela mais en fait
j'étais chez moi je vais la télé en fond
et je les ai entendues j'y ai pas vu
d'abord
le
chaud
j'ai entendu d'abord l'envoi je me suis
retournée c'est là que j'ai vu c'était
des prêtres d'accord elle avait raison
qui dit quand elle parlait justement des
prêts dans la musique aujourd'hui la
famille lefebvre exemple rôle de la
musique classique un peu un peu
christique comme ça ça ça a beaucoup de
succès mieux que des mâles est à 2
minutes non non non non non personne
[Musique]
m
pire on a la chance de l'avoir avec nous
par skype
jean pierre qui est vraiment un mec que
j'admire beaucoup et qui adore
jean-pierre salut à tous jean pire je
suis très heureux de voir ce soir tu ne
voudrais pas mon année quand mon
voilà maman de jean pire vous êtes
témoin atalian oui oui parce que en ya
beaucoup d'émotions soir dans des
motions son départ de demain ces belles
images pour demain grâce à toi guillaume
merci je sais que jean pierre c'était
son son mentor sa mère et c'est très dur
pour lui aussi je le remercie de d'avoir
accepté d'avoir donné les images